One of the cultural differences between East and West is about saying "No."
Foreigners want an exact "Yes" or "No" unlike Korean culture where being nice is appreciated.
For Koreans, rejecting a request outright is considered very bad manners,...
...because we may offend the other person, feel selfish, or make the other person feel embarrassed...
...for having asked, and they may lose face.
In the Western sphere, especially in the business environment, there are no such considerations.
In fact, saying "No" is considered a strength.
Having agreed to carry out a task without actually doing it is seen as unreliable and untrustworthy...
...especially if you omit giving a valid excuse or explanation.
This cultural misunderstanding leads to frustration and often angers.
People are more expected to acknowledge their limitations and act accordingly.
If you cannot possibly complete a task, you need to say "No."
This way, someone else can take over and whatever task or process is not delayed.